como vamos a usar estos productos que
vamos a desarmar a excepción de la
botella para crear algo valioso y
novedoso con todos los componentes
individuales lo que hicimos fue diseñar
un nuevo producto para que los niños se
emocionen por las matemáticas y las
ciencias y para sacar el máximo provecho
de estos productos necesitamos
incorporar elementos electrónicos por lo
que tenemos un arduino que básicamente
es un circuito programable y que puede
conectarse fácilmente con otros
componentes para hacer prototipos y
tenemos un circuito l 298 que es un
controlador de motor este que ven aquí
viene en un kit que hay que armar y nos
permitirá controlar la dirección y
rapidez de nuestros motores para que
podamos mover nuestro pequeño robot
también tenemos un pequeño sistema de
sonido lo que nos permitirá grabar y
reproducir audio de manera que todo lo
controlamos con nuestro arduino el
controlador del motor obviamente nos
permitirá manipular el motor como
queramos y esto nos permitirá grabar y
reproducir sonidos
vamos a usar algunos de los componentes
de estos productos para crear algo
genial después de tres semanas de
desarrollo creamos a bits y bot que es
un pequeño robot programable que se
mueve y tiene cierta personalidad
podemos controlar a bits y con un
control remoto universal fue de 1 que
teníamos y desarmamos y envía una señal
hasta aquí a nuestro sensor que a su vez
se comunica con nuestro arduino y
entonces él arduino puede encender o
apagar ciertas funciones de manera que
podemos hacer que beats y baile y
encienda sus luces bits y tiene un par
de interruptores uno aquí y otro acá
estos los tomamos de la radio y pueden
ver que la nariz de bicing viene de la
tapa de un refresco al igual que esos
ojos
la energía de vichy viene de estas
baterías que colocamos en esta
cartuchera para baterías los motores
vienen de la secadora de cabello y aquí
hay un motor de secadora y básicamente
usamos esto como rueda para que bits y
se mueva bits y también tiene la
habilidad de grabar y reproducir sonidos
por lo que usamos esto y usamos el
control remoto para usar esta función
también tenemos el controlador del motor
que obviamente usamos para controlar la
rapidez y dirección del motor
aquí colocamos la cámara que desarmamos
que era como esta y la podemos usar para
tomar fotos nuevamente con el arduino
controlamos esto mediante el control
remoto aquí vemos la tableta en donde
todo está conectado y que parece una
galleta ya que este objeto nos permite
conectar más cosas al arduino tenemos
varias resistencias y transistores las
resistencias nos sirven para limitar el
flujo de corriente y los transistores
funcionan como interruptores por lo que
nos permiten controlar diferentes
dispositivos con nuestro arduino
así pues esta es beat sí y tiene
personalidad como pueden ver se
encienden sus ojos y hace diferentes
cosas cuando presionamos su defensa o
cuando golpea algo veremos más sobre
bits y en los siguientes vídeos